highly contagious strains of the
coronavirus are spreading across this
country
the cdc has recorded nearly 1 000 cases
of the three variants
first reported in britain brazil and
south africa across
35 states and now we're getting new
insights into how the virus mutates
from a team of doctors who studied one
extraordinary case
extraordinary is the word here carter
evans is following the story
carter good morning we've never heard
anything like this gail good morning
this is the story of a 45 year old man
in boston who had a covet 19 variant for
five months before he died now during
that time his doctors found the virus
inside of him had mutated get this
more than 20 times now this is an
extraordinary case
considering the life cycle of the virus
in a healthy person is typically only
around two weeks
now the reason why it lasted so long is
because the man was immunocompromised
like an estimated
10 million other americans but in this
case the man's immune response
wasn't strong enough to fully eradicate
the virus it was
just strong enough that it forced the
virus to adapt and essentially mutate
now the doctors who treated him
published a report on this in november
but the story is now getting renewed
attention
with the emergence of variants like the
one from south africa and the one in the
uk
we spoke with one of these doctors his
name is jonathan lee
he says this case is shedding light on
how the virus adapts
i think this particular case is in
retrospect a harbinger
of what was to come and i think that it
just goes to show that
we need to do a better job of monitoring
the spread of these variants
and that only by looking for these
variants will we be able to detect it
and that it's something that i think we
haven't done as well
up to now
carter you know this disease this virus
continues to baffle surprise and scared
we're hearing a lot about those variants
from south africa and the uk but in the
last few weeks
cases in this country seem to have been
steadily declining so do you think the
variance could change that
well dr anthony fauci has really been
warning about this he's saying there's
evidence that people who've recovered
from the coronavirus can get
re-infected with these variants and
that's why there's more
urgency than ever to speed up our
vaccine roll out so more people
have some measure of protection and the
virus will have
less of an opportunity to mutate it's
also going to give vaccine developers
time to work on boosters to better
protect against mutations but the key
gail
is going to be doing the genetic testing
to detect these mutations
when they get out into the wild yeah
still so much to learn thank you carter